woman named Stacey Abrams gave the
Democratic rebuttal to the State of the
Union address last night Abrams is not
an officeholder she's a former state
legislator from Georgia
she lost the governor's race there in
the last election nevertheless party
leaders clearly have big plans for
Abrams her speech last night wasn't much
she talked mostly about herself
but far more interesting is a piece that
Abrams wrote in this month's foreign
affairs magazine the piece is called
identity politics strengthens democracy
and if you want to understand what the
Democratic Party seeks for this country
you ought to read the piece Abra's went
to Yale Law School so the article itself
is a chore to get through it's written
in that cloying indirect academic style
that passes for area dition among our
credentialed elites lots of meaningless
adjectives very few declarative
sentences but you'll get the point
anyway it's crystal clear quote by
embracing identity Abrams writes in the
final sentence Americans will become
more likely to grow as one so ponder
that for a second the less we have in
common the more united we will be is
that true well of course not it's absurd
even stacey abrams doesn't really
believe it nobody does Abrams doesn't
even bother to defend that premise much
less explain how exactly identity
politics will unite this country unity
is definitely not what stacey abrams is
interested in just the opposite what
she's selling is bitter division Abram
spends the bulk of the piece calling on
what she describes as the marginalized
to unite against the quote dominant
groups so who is marginalized and who is
dominant that's not a small question in
the scheme of identity politics it's the
only question that matters everything
rides on who's the victim and who's the
oppressor that's the entire equation and
Abrams spells out the answer in very
clear language the marginalize she
writes include quote women Native
Americans african-americans immigrants
and the LGBTQ community the dominant are
everyone who's left so do the
subtraction that's only one group you
know exactly who they are and so to
Stacey Abrams
she says these people these unnamed
people are responsible for the suffering
of everyone else and we need to
overthrow them she uses the language of
violence and war to describe what must
come next quote politics is the most
affected method of revolt revolt people
get hurt in revolts that's the nature of
revolts Stacey Abrams knows that she
once won anyway she doesn't hide it
demagoguery like this would make a
certain kind of sense if your only
interest was in winning elections and
you didn't care about what happened
afterward
that's where Democrats are right now the
Democratic Party is a highly unstable
collection of interest groups many of
them with radically different interests
and goals it's not a natural coalition
there's no reason all of these groups
should be voting for the same candidates
in every election the only way to keep a
fractious group like this together is by
inventing economy enemy that everyone
can oppose you're one of us if you hate
these people
now this often works in the short term
it worked for Democrats in the chimp
Rose south for about a hundred years and
that's why they still do it the problem
is that these people these dominant
groups as Stacey Abrams says aren't some
foreign invader from a faraway land
they're your countrymen you're not
supposed to hate them or hurt them
revolt against them they is us we're in
this together we're all Americans that's
the most important thing really the only
important thing Stacey Abrams doesn't
see it that way neither do the leaders
of her party they think they can win the
next election by telling Americans they
must hate their neighbors for the color
of their skin it's possible this will
work one more time but then what happens
after the election Abrams doesn't answer
that question inner peace she doesn't
care but the rest of us should think
about it no election is worth the hatred
and the division of identity politics
not if you plan to live here anyway
elections in this country used to be
based on issues or that was the common
agreement anyway but what would happen
to a country in which power is allocated
on the basis of qualities you couldn't
control things you were born with your
skin color your gender your genetics
that would be called identity politics